foreign
in Indianapolis what's up Justin
hey how's it going Dr John I'm good hey
uh you're not working at that there's
like a big fire going on there right now
huh
no I I would know anything about that
no fire here
[Laughter]
just in your heart hey that's awesome
dude okay so what's up
Hey so uh I'm 23 and I'm getting married
in July congratulations
so we are excited and um we are huge
Dave Ramsey people too so we've got all
the baby steps and all that stuff lined
up and um
so we are I work at a CNC shop and I
have unlimited overtime so essentially I
am gearing up to just absolutely grind
it out and pile up as much money as I
can so we can buy a house and do all
that stuff the Ramsay way and what's
what's a CNC
shop uh it's computer and air control so
I'll uh essentially I use crazy machines
that sounds so great
it's so much fun I love it you know what
I am I love my job I'm a podcaster
I know but you can take machines and cut
metal me that's so awesome
ah and Angie Over Here Andrew over here
is running the board he can take that
metal and melt it together with fire I
don't know I just I I'm uh I'm
embarrassed to be on the phone with you
is what I'm saying so all right so go
ahead so you're you've got the
opportunity to just essentially
earn a ton of money by working your butt
off over the next however many months
yes and I love my job so I'm perfectly
willing to do that excellent
it has expressed concerns that she she
says she understands all the Dave Ramsey
stuff she says that she gets that we
need to you know really really buckle
down and really grind it out now in
these next coming years so we can really
get a good foundation for our family and
start things off on the right track
which is great and I'm a very blessed
man for her understanding however she
did say that she's a little bit
concerned that I might be working too
much and that she's concerned about me
being present in the first couple months
first couple years of our marriage so I
guess my question is how do I what are
some good ways to like balance
you know really getting gazelle intense
really grinding things out and really
working hard at my job and you know
making the money to ensure our future
but also you know
um dedicating and investing in my
marriage as well
it's a great question man I wish more
people were this intentional on this
side of it usually people come to me
when their marriages are hanging on by
dental floss and trying to save it and
you are being wise and intelligent and
on the front end so good for you man for
everybody listening um if you don't know
Dave Ramsey's stuff is what he's talking
about is
um
for 30 years Dave's been teaching people
how to get out of debt to stop owing
people money and you hear me talk a lot
about the the psychological issues with
owing people money but also there's a
wealth building component there's how to
buy a house and how to buy cars and how
to
um invest and things like that so
um you're way down the road there Justin
here's here's what I think
is going to get you all into trouble and
here's a simple path out of it okay
um have you heard me talk about pictures
and words before
a little bit okay here's uh here's a
recap of pictures and words
um is the great William Glasser who's a
psychiatrist back in the day who
actually swore off psychiatry in a way
um he he's the one who gave me this idea
we
think in pictures but we speak in words
what I mean by that is you're about to
get married and you have a picture in
your mind of what the word husband means
and in your mind I'm guessing a husband
is a guy who works really hard
and he's a provider and he looks at a
goal 15 years down the road when it
comes to paying for kids college kids
that aren't even born yet
paying off a house making sure your
family's safe providing food all those
things
your wife has a picture of husband
of a guy who walks in at exactly five
zero zero every day who neatly puts his
clothes away and who is smelling so good
and who just sits down to a nice and I'm
completely gender stereotyping this
thing by the way and sits down to a nice
dinner and smiles and then y'all all
watch TV and she falls asleep in your
arms
now both of you
deeply love each other
both of you are deeply committed to each
other
and you are going to go a hundred miles
an hour towards your picture of the word
husband
and she is going to go a hundred miles
an hour trying to make the picture a
husband in her head possible
and y'all are both gonna go a thousand
miles an hour going opposite directions
from each other
and so when you come home at seven
o'clock or ten o'clock at night having
busted your butt in a hot Warehouse in
the summer cutting metal
she's going to be sitting at home
heartbroken that she's done something
wrong that her husband rather hang out
with machines than her
and then when you come home at five
o'clock you're going to be looking at
your watch the whole time going it's
we're never going to get a home
so the magic here is not how do I find
the balance balance is an illusion it's
not real that's a fake word so it's a
waste of time to go towards it what I
want you guys to do is to get really
clear and United on these pictures
here is what my picture when I hear the
word wife here's what's in my head when
she hears the word wife here's the
picture in her head
what kind of house do we want to live in
and when do we think we want to buy one
how much money would it take and just
reverse engineer it that means that if I
worked 48 hours a week for the next two
years I could make this thing happen or
if I worked 80 hours for one year we
could have a house
and now what you're doing is y'all are
just weighing what kind of life you want
to live
you're not weighing that's too much work
that's not enough work you're never home
for dinner you're not all those
questions go away
when you decide together here's the life
we want to have
and so for us I wanted a life outside of
higher education someday
I wanted a life where I wasn't on call
24 7 365 all the time
and so what that meant was for three or
four years I was gonna go back to
college I already had a PhD I was done
I'm gonna go back I'm gonna get trained
in something else
so that I have different options and so
what that meant was every couple of
weeks my wife and I were meeting like
this is awful I'm writing papers every
Saturday instead of playing with my
young kid and I'm reading books in the
middle of the night instead of going to
concerts and all that we gave up that
moment and now we're living a bananas
life like a cartoon
but we sacrificed but we did it together
you see what I'm saying
so yeah those things took care of
themselves and so I'd love for you and
your wife to sit down and say
let's let's just tell her exactly what I
told you about pictures and words and
what marriage like when I see marriage
in my head you're probably going to
default to what your parents did she's
going to develop to what her home life
was like you know I'm gonna try to make
this thing work and that's where that
tension comes from
all right so speak back I talked at you
a lot tell me tell me what you're
thinking
we're going you know marriage counseling
we're
we're raising parents and we've just
come from two great families so we're
doing marriage counseling all that stuff
so we actually have marriage counseling
this evening so we're having we always
have dinner before and kind of talk
about our week and stuff so I was going
to talk to her about about whatever it
is we talked about this evening at
dinner and yeah that uh that pictures
and words that really makes sense to me
so I'm following you there awesome and I
just I just I am desperate to give this
woman everything that she deserves
because I am the luckiest man in the
world and I love her more than anything
in the world so that's all trying to be
prepared so the greatest gift you could
give her on the front end is Extreme
clarity
about what you
often especially husbands but wives too
especially husbands
we get in our head I want to give my
wife everything
well I may have talked about this on the
show this is this is a private
conversation between me and my wife so I
don't know if I have or not
um I really want my wife to have a
handsome husband
and I can't do much about my face
I got stuck with that one
but I can stay in the gym
especially with how much how bad I eat
sometimes and I really want my wife to
never ever ever worry about money ever
I wanted to do whatever she wants
whenever she wants
and so
I'm gonna work like crazy all of the
time to always be earning always be
earning always have another line in the
water another Prospect another book on
the horizon I always want to be earning
and it was during a Christmas holiday
not this year but the previous year when
I was sick and I was down in our little
home gym lifting weights I was lifting
heavy and I can be kind of obnoxious
loud and whatever
and she came down and just said what are
you doing
I was like I'll mark it out what and she
came and got really close to me and
she's shorter than me and she got real
close
she said on a pie chart that is our life
together
the looks department is filled
the next exercise you do is not for me
it's for your ego you're welcome to stay
down here but you cannot tell yourself
or anyone else that you're doing this
for me
and she said while I'm here when it
comes to money we have enough
what I don't have enough of is you
when I realized Justin is I was using
what I thought she wanted and I was
trying to give it to her and I never
bothered to ask her occasionally I would
ask her and I wouldn't believe her
occasionally I would be like hey and
she'd be like you look great I'd much
rather you be up with us once or twice a
week for breakfast instead of spending
an hour and a half down in the basement
and I'd be like yeah she says that now
but one day
what if I just trusted my wife
right so it goes back to asking
um and then I'm gonna give you this one
thing you're going to find as you in as
a newly married 23 year old Danielle or
young dude
um you're gonna find yourself not
knowing what you're doing
and work is going to become a great
distraction a great drug my good friend
Ian simkin says if busyness is your drug
then rest will feel like stress
if you medicate yourself with busyness
and with more work and more work and
more work resting will feel anxious
so you gotta be honest with yourself
about whether you're using work for a
season we need to earn this much money
so we can get a down payment for this
house and so I'm going to work this many
hours for this long we're gonna get this
thing done or
I miss endlessly working forever and
ever and ever amen because I'm good at
that I'm not good at being married right
now I don't know what I'm doing
y'all gonna have to build into your
relationship conversations and ways of
talking and if y'all will connect your
pictures together if y'all will be
crystal clear about what you're both
aiming at
man you will be so far ahead of every
couple I talk to not everyone most of
them
um be clear about your pictures make
sure your words and pictures match
and set up a plan together and then just
go get it congratulations on getting
married man let me know how it goes